in September 1978 America's close ally
in the Muslim Middle East Iran is rocked
by anti-government riots the crowds
Islamists communist liberals come
together in opposition to the dictator
the Shah of Iran for almost four decades
America has relied on Reza Shah Pahlavi
Shan Shan Shan's Oh King of Kings rulers
of Iran and all its people honey he lets
Iran's vast oil wealth go only to the
few he promotes Western culture enraging
millions of Muslims the Shahs power is
maintained by a vicious secret police
and the fifth largest military on earth
equipped with American weapons
now President Carter calls an emergency
meeting our presumption was that the
United States policies would be better
off if the Shah did stay in power we
were concerned that did shuffles the
whole thing could become extremely
unstable
not just in Iran but in the region but
over how to save the Shah
the president's advisors are divided a
secretary Vance and I both felt that the
best chance the Shah had to maintain his
position was to go the direction of
reform to have early elections to take
human rights steps that would injure
would gain the confidence of his people
you first reestablish order there by
asserting your authority and the shortly
thereafter initiated reforms having
proven that you're in charge
Brzezinski felt we should make it very
clear to the Shah that we would not
object in any way if he decided to
really crack down very hard then use
what Brezinski came to call the iron
fist but the message to the Shah isn't
clear it urges him both to get tough
with the protesters and to offer them
concessions the Shah summons the US
ambassador William Sullivan his majesty
Austin concurs America wants me to take
a hard line ambassador Sullivan had to
say I have no instructions on this your
majesty which left it that they char
very confused the Shah sees no choice
but to try to embrace the
revolutionaries melody your own
inimitable Admiralty demand as the Shah
of Iran Iranian I cannot disapprove of
my People's Revolution I promise to
uphold the Constitution and the people's
will I will not allow a rainy or
corruption they do resume a facade ha ha
the shan ounces that he and his family
will soon be taking an extended holiday
soon after the Shah and his wife leave
Iran
the more that you scare I've been
feeling I need some of this